thank you all for for giving me this
opportunity to talk to you and I know it
is quite a challenge after lunch to get
you interested in a subject like
resource mobilization so I hope you know
I will succeed in energizing you getting
your interest in this subject well yes
but but now I have a real challenge
because I'm not asking you for money I'm
just asking you for your interest in
where the money is coming from but I I
think we can discuss a really exciting
story because what happened over the
last decade has been absolutely
unprecedented the amount of money that
has been mobilized for global health and
I want to go a little bit into the
details you know where is this money
coming from what does it take to
mobilize this money and also what's the
prospect for the future and I know that
many of you are engaged in implementing
probably programs that receive financial
support from PEPFAR from the glow fan
from from gavi from other funders and
you might not necessarily think about
you know how do these organizations get
the money but there is a lot of work
sometimes also hard work to convince
politicians you know congressional
members in the US and in Parliament's
around the world so that they allocate
the money that you very often will then
have the responsibility to utilize in
your countries and turn that into life
saving programs so that's why I hope you
know you will see the link between what
I have to say this afternoon and your
own work in the countries but i will
also emphasize that we do need your
support as well your kind of feedback
from the country's is absolutely
critical for us when we go out to talk
to the politicians and to those who in
the end make the decisions about the
financial resources so let me then go
into the details where the money came
from and what happened over the last
couple of years we have really seen an
unprecedented increase in financing for
global health that is this graph from
the publication last year in The Lancet
that shows that between 19
gnite in 2007 the financial resources
for global health increased from 5.5
billion u.s. dollars to 21 billion
dollars and I don't think we have ever
seen certainly nothing like that in
health but I would also claim not in any
other area of development we haven't
seen anything like that in education or
you know hygiene and sanitation or
environmental protection or any other
you know important area so that
something has happened here that is
really quite outstanding and there are a
number of factors and the US has
certainly played a key role in this
because some of the largest locations
for international health have come from
the US government but also from the
private sector in front particularly
from the foundations and obviously the
outstanding example here is the creation
of the Bill and Melinda Gates Foundation
in the year 2000 that also contributed
enormously to the increase in resources
to global health but then also from a
number of other countries from the UK
Japan Germany France Netherlands and
other countries they all increased their
allocation to international health a
very special event was the creation of
PEPFAR in 2003 and you see here the
location of pepra by far the largest
bilateral program in health that has
ever been established by any country in
the world and you're all probably very
familiar with the impact of PEPFAR in
the countries where you are working now
another question is then you know this
money for which health problems so if
you look at the slides you know 14.5
billion of this money out of the 45
billion in 2007 that was allocated
overall 5.1 billion went to AIDS zero
point seven billion for tuberculosis
zero point eight billion for malaria and
zero point nine billion for health
sector support so we've seen an overall
increase but certainly you know that the
share of the increased money
or AIDS was the largest and then the
question is now why did all of this
happen and why so much money went into
AIDS and I think that is very important
to understand the context also for
advocacy also when we look into the
future later on and we have to
understand that something very special
happen to you for the first time in
history we've seen a solidarity movement
between people living with a certain
disease in this case hiv/aids in the
north in the wealthy countries and
people living with the same disease in
the south it was a particular moment
when people living in rich countries
suffering from hiv/aids knowing that
their life dependent depended on the
availability of you know money so that
they could buy the drugs that this was
the same disease that millions of people
are dying from in the south and then to
say we demand the same right to life the
same right to access to this life-saving
medication that we have and we want that
to be available worldwide we really have
to kind of contemplate for a minute what
that meant because it has never happened
with any other disease nor with any
other health problem or any other
problem I would say so there's something
very special and so the best expression
for me is what justice Edwin Cameron
said you know at the AIDS Conference in
Durban 2000 which for me still is a kind
of defining moment in the history of not
only the fight against hiv/aids but also
in the mobilization of political support
for health in general so he said at this
conference in Durban I stand before you
because I am able to purchase health I'm
here because I can pay for life itself
to me this seems a shocking a monstrous
inequity that simply because of relative
affluence I should be living when others
have died our overriding and immediate
commitment should be to find ways to
make accessible for the poor what is
in reach of the effluent this sentence
summarizes the whole movement that has
been behind this mobilization of
resources and it has been repeated you
know by many other leaders in this field
and it has reached then the influential
people that are the politicians those
who make the financial decisions but it
started with a statement like that there
is of course a question why only an AIDS
and when will we see a similar movement
also for other health problems because
you could easily see that also other
people let's say you know a woman who
gives birth here in the hospital in New
Haven and has a cesarean section and you
know her life and the life of her baby
to the availability of wonderful
facilities in maternal care why should
that not be available in all countries
around the world so that you know we can
reduce maternal mortality and other
problems we haven't seen this kind of
movement yet but I do believe that this
you know is a promise for the future
that you know might also materialize one
day but it clearly happened with with
AIDS let me go into a few other
explanations why there was what I
believe has been a paradigm shift in the
whole thinking and understanding of
global health the first is the
understanding of health as a human right
and this is not a new idea at all you
know it has been in un documents in the
charter of Human Rights it has been
expressed many times but I believe it
has never been taken really seriously if
you read what but the UN Charter says
everyone has the right to standard of
living adequate for the health and
well-being of himself and off his family
and there is an international obligation
to make this happen but it was kind of
considered is soft right in a sense of
social right not a kind of you know
civil right and therefore not to be
implemented by countries around the
world and i think the aid solidarity
movement has contributed to put you know
health as a human right back on the
political agenda and therefore had also
contributed to the impact that we've
seen before there's also another
argument that is very important and
actually I'm very pleased that that
gorrik has joined us because goreck has
has promoted that idea that i very much
supported the question of sustainability
as self sufficiency and to move from
sustainability as self sufficiency into
you know sustainable global solidarity
I've worked myself as a medical doctor
for some years in in Tanzania in his
Africa and I think you know I understand
very much the situations you know in
which you work and also when I was
working there when I was implementing
primary healthcare it was with the
understanding that you know yes you can
support that externally but but it
should be self-sufficient primary
healthcare was something that you know
communities could maintain themselves it
was not something that required
international solidarity as a right to
kind of support these services but when
we entered into the era of providing
antiretroviral treatment globally it was
clear that this was not just a kind of
short to measure that we give it to
people for one or two years but then you
know people or communities or
governments should become
self-sufficient but it was with the full
understanding that this would have to be
maintained long term we are talking
about lifelong treatment here and not
about something you know that that we
can phase out and I'm not talking here
about middle-income countries that might
well be in a position to do that over
time but a lot of countries will require
this international solidarity for a long
time and I do think they have the right
to receive this solidarity and also
there is a kind of trend from moving
from development aids to kind of system
of global social security we have
observed a gradual shift from
development aid to still rudimentary but
emerging form of a global social
security system that is my deep
conviction and I think that's what we
have to work on in a globalized world we
should accept the argument that risks
need to be shared more widely and that a
person should not be refused the right
to education food water or health care
just because he or she was born in a
country that cannot afford a minimum of
social protection so these paradigm
shifts in the understanding of global
health and the powerful advocacy
spearheaded by AIDS activists from
around the world had to converge to
result in the increased resource
allocation we've seen in recent years
and then as a result of that movement we
got this political support at the
highest possible level and you know the
person who probably did most to promote
that was then secretary-general of the
United Nations Kofi Annan and he brought
together many leaders political leaders
NGO leaders private sector and others he
organized the UN General Assembly
special session on hv 8 the first time
that the General Assembly ever discussed
you know health problem at that level
they issued a declaration supported by
all the member states of the UN and part
of that declaration was the call for
what Kofi Annan called a war chest for
the fight against hiv/aids and that was
the beginning of the Global Fund that
was then created shortly after that
right after this UN General Assembly in
june 2001 there was the jade summit in
genoise that provided the first money
for the Global Fund and Kofi Annan
pushed everybody very hard so that the
Global Fund could be established in
January 2002 just six month after this
UN General Assembly so if you now look
at you know what happened with the
resources over time you see a very steep
increase from the early years just in
the response to hiv/aids and you see the
kind of very important
Mark's here creation of the Gates
Foundation the UN General Assembly then
declared creation of the Global Fund
pepper and so on and then we've seen an
exponential growth in the resources over
the last few years so but I also want to
emphasize that this why aids played a
very important role in this whole
movement the resources that have been
mobilized have not been restricted to
hiv/aids at all and let me just give you
a few examples and start with vaccine
and immunizations there there is the
Global Alliance for vaccines and
immunizations Garvey that has been
created in two thousand that is
supporting many countries around the
world providing access to the
immunizations for children the standard
immunizations that have been used for a
long time but also helping countries
introduce new vaccines that so far had
been out of reach for many countries
like hepatitis B and currently Garvey is
involved in the rollout of new vaccines
rotavirus vaccines and pneumococcal
vaccines that are available but
currently still too expensive for many
countries around the world and that's
exactly what I described as the paradigm
shift that while we would have accepted
that 20 years ago that here you have
these vaccines you use them in the US
use them in Europe but you don't make
them available for the millions of
children time from diarrhea and from
pneumonia this has changed and we do now
know that we have to make those
resources available so that people
access in this case vaccines
particularly affecting childhood
diseases and another very important
discussion now is around maternal health
what many regarded as a kind of
neglected health problem and I would
fully agree with that although resources
for maternal health has also increased
over the last few years and there are
data to show that in the year two
thousand and three 2.1 billion dollars
were available for maternal health and
in 2007 4.1 billion so it's not that no
resources have gone into that and that's
why also
always argue that we don't take money
away from one cause to the other which
we try to mobilize resources for health
in general but certainly it has not been
the same increase that we've seen for
hiv/aids but particularly this year
we've seen an unprecedented political
mobilization around maternal and child
health and most prominently of that is
the initiative started by the g8
presidency of Canada and while the g8
summit will only happen tomorrow I have
here on the screen for you what I've
received as the draft of the final
communique and I trust that you will not
quote me today because I'm sure it is
under embargo today but I hope you will
see that you know tomorrow or the day
after but it is no secret that the
Canadian government has pushed very hard
for this initiative and this is what we
expect to be in the final document where
they say progress towards MTG 5
improving maternal health has been
unacceptably slow and consequently we
the leaders off the Jade working with
other partners in developing countries
launch today the most coca initiative a
comprehensive and integrated approach to
contribute to progress towards mdg four
and five that will significantly reduce
the number of maternal newborn and under
five child deaths in developing
countries and I guess that many of you
will appreciate this this initiative
because I guess that many of you will be
working on these issues and in line with
the the g8 presidency also the current
UN secular General Ban ki-moon has
launched an initiative on maternal and
child health he is working on a joint
action plan that he will launch at the
millennium summit of all the heads of
state meeting in September this year in
New York and finally also the African
Union summit in July and Kampala will
focus on maternal and child health and
the African Union has been working more
than a year on that program
so just to show you you know sometimes
how you can create a momentum of you
know political support political will
but again it's related to health and
that is very important it's you know
it's expanding its moving also from AIDS
TB malaria to other areas but health has
been and I guess we'll still be very
high on the political agenda and
admitting is like the UN assembly like
the g8 and others so now I turn to the
organization I work for the Global Fund
to fight AIDS tuberculosis and malaria
but not only because I obviously love
that organization but also because I
wanted to use the Global Fund as a kind
of example how you can mobilize
resources and what is required for
successful advocacy because one of the
key areas that you need is you have to
demonstrate that the instrument you are
promoting is innovative and is producing
results which means advocacy can only be
successful if you have a product if you
like that you can really sell to
politicians it's not just a PR activity
it's not and thank you Mike for your
very kind words you know that I can be
persuasive in US Congress but I wouldn't
be able to be persuasive if the Global
Fund wasn't working I wouldn't be able
to persuade anybody to give money to an
organization to an instrument that was
dysfunctional that was not demonstrating
results it's impossible so that's my
first very important statement whatever
we are advocating for you need to have
an instrumented channel in a sense that
you can present to politicians and then
convince them and that by the way will
be the same challenge now as we are
moving into maternal and child health
and increasing their focus ii for that
also then you will need a kind of
channel that you can present to
politicians so what are the and this is
then a slide that that shows the
increase of the resources of the Global
Fund since its creation and in
2001 I talked about the UN General
Assembly and you see that there has been
a kind of constant increase in the
resources that donors both from the
public and the private sector made
available to the glow of fun to fight
AIDS tuberculosis malaria we started in
the in the early days with about 800 900
million dollars per year and then we
moved you know two to three and now this
year probably the income of the Global
Fund will be around 3.6 billion dollars
so why is that and let me mention a
couple of key let's say aspects of the
Global Fund that have enabled us to go
around the world talking governments
talking to private companies to persuade
them that this is an instrument they can
invest in the first of those is what we
call performance-based funding and some
of you might be actually quite familiar
with the Global Fund model if you're
working you know with fun grunts then
you know that the glow fund has a very
strict system in a sense to you know
approve grants that have very clear
targets very clear indicators that are
measurable that can be validated and
that the disbursement then follows the
actual performance of the grounds and
the achievements of results and I am
aware that sometimes that might also be
burdensome for for many of the countries
we are working in but it is a kind of
precondition because if we wouldn't have
those results if we were not able to
show and demonstrate measurable results
we would never be able to mobilize
they're the kind of resources that we
have been able to mobilize another
aspect is what we call value for money
we always have to demonstrate to the
donors that what we do is not only
effective achieving results but also
efficient that we are achieving those
results with the least resources
possible and I can tell you in this
current economic climate that is
probably the question I get most you
know what do you pay for the services
what you pay for the drugs can you
reduce the cost for the drugs can you
achieve more with the same amount of
money
and that is not always easy and I know
that also often puts pressure on you
maybe in the implementation of the
programs but it's one of the key
questions that we get that we can
demonstrate this efficiency and finally
also the aspect of accountability and
transparency that you know these the
grants are fully accountable that we are
transparent that we put all our
disbursements on the website that we
have an independent inspector general
who is reporting back to our board it's
all meant to increase the confidence of
the donors in this instrument which is
absolutely essential for the advocacy
than to work and the last aspect of that
that is extremely important for the glow
fund is the governance structure and the
Global Fund has a very innovative
governance structure because on our
board you have the representatives of
the public sector the government's both
from the donor governments and from the
implementing countries the private
sector civil society and you have the
technical partners like wo urinates and
the World Bank sitting on our board now
having all of these you know
representatives on the board that is not
so innovative but what is innovative is
the decision-making structure of the
global fund because every board
representative has the same vote whether
you're a donor whether you are an NGO
whether you're an NGO coming from Africa
or whether you are the representative of
Japan whether you are the representative
of the private sector or of the
Foundation's you have one vote there are
20 members and they are divided into two
blocks the donors and the implementers
and you need a two-third majority to
make any decision that means no group
can dominate the other and I would claim
that this is the only multi-billion
dollar organization in the world where
donors you know commit more than 300
billion dollars every year but grant the
same decision making power to those who
do not contribute with money
but who implement this money and turn
this money into results whether your
representative of a government or of a
civil society that's the decision-making
structure of the Global Fund and it has
been absolutely critical also for the
adverse effects of the fund because and
I will come to that in a minute the very
important in our advocacy has been the
support particularly from civil society
both from the north and from the south
and this advocacy this you know energy
this enthusiasm you get from society
around the world you only get because
they feel the ownership they say this is
our instrument it might not be perfect
nobody thinks the glow of art is perfect
there are lots of things that we
constantly have to review and to improve
but it is our instrument where we are
part of the decision maker we can change
it we are working all the time you know
to adapt the systems to simplify at the
moment we are reviewing the whole
architecture so this kind of ownership
then leads to effective advocacy and
finally what is obviously very important
is that you can then demonstrate real
results that we can go out to the donors
and tell them what happens with the
money so currently we have approved
grants more than 600 programs in 144
countries worth nineteen point two
billion dollars and that makes the
global founder the major investor
worldwide and AIDS tuberculosis and
malaria the donor so far have pledged
about 22 billion dollars of which 16
billion have been paid in and I will
come to the distribution of the income
in a minute but more important is what
this money then has translated into into
the concrete results in the fight
against the three diseases and we report
those results very regularly every six
month and we just got the latest results
out in end of June currently the Global
Fund is supporting 2.8 million people on
antiretroviral treatment six million
people are receiving tuberculosis
treatment and we have
countries to distribute 120 million
impregnated mosquito nets so those are
them the results that we can really
demonstrate and go back to the donors
and report on and this is not just in
terms of the services that drugs the bed
nets but in the end it has to translate
into reduced mobility and reduced
mortality so you want to see in the end
what kind of impact does this investment
have and this year in particular as we
have the review of the millennium
development goals and as the global fund
was created to help countries achieve
the Millennium Development Goals there
will be particular you know scrutiny of
where we are in terms of the achievement
of the MDGs this shows the numbers i
just mentioned but also the kind of
increases that we see from year to year
so for example on on antiretroviral
treatment twenty-two percent more people
on treatment compared to the year before
in terms of bed nets even thirty-nine
percent more than in the year before so
that's the results we can demonstrate
but if we then look at what has happened
with that in terms of impact let's look
at the three diseases malaria in 2002
was basically a neglected disease there
was very little funding available for
malaria and that was also my experience
when I worked in Tanzania I had
basically no resources except for
chlorine and Keenan and the most basic
treatment and there were no bed nets
available in the villages and that I
think has really changed and I hope that
many of you have seen that in the
countries where you work and that we
really see now a decrease in morbidity
and mortality in countries and our know
in many countries it's now between fifty
and eighty percent decrease for this
disease similarly TB in 2002 was
basically neglected disease very little
international funding available now we
have you know millions of people who
have received dots treatment we have
improved a Diagnostics case detection
but also cure rates and basically for
the closest we can probably go to the
millennium summit in September and say
we are on track to achieve the mdg on
tuberculosis you have the numbers here
there were very clear targets the the
incidence rate was 220 in two thousand
and the target for 2015 is 124 and we
are currently at 164 at new cases per
100,000 so that is exactly on track of
where we should be to decrease Juba
closest incidence and then on on
hiv/aids ten years ago when the soul
movement started there was hardly
anybody with access to antiretroviral
treatment in Africa and in other
developing countries except for Brazil
now we have five million people on
treatment largely due to the support of
PEPFAR and the glow fund but we've also
seen as you certainly know a decrease in
prevalence and infection rates in many
countries although going down slowly and
we have to redouble our efforts to
combat this disease so this is the
message that that we will present it to
the MDGs summit we also emphasized the
interconnectedness of the MDGs because
there has been the argument that the s
you've done quite a lot on AIDS
tuberculosis malaria but you have not
made progress on for example maternal
and child health and as I said before I
agree more needs to be done in this area
but we also have to see that aids
tuberculosis malaria are still major
causes of death for children and for
women particularly in Africa and
therefore there has also been progress
on that and we now need to look at the
health-related MDGs together there's a
kind of comprehensive program so that's
the kind of background if you like for
the advocacy that I wanted to talk about
because only if you can demonstrate that
then you can really mobilize the
political support and this political
support also includes the support of
leaders from your countries without
your ministers of health without your
presidents and prime ministers to speak
up at the international meetings when
they meet with leaders from other
countries we would never get to the
resources we need one element that has
been quite critical has been to mobilize
some key influences who have the direct
access to people who finally make the
budgetary decisions and that has been
critical in our advocacy effort not just
for the Global Fund but for health
overall that we were able to mobilize
people like Kofi Annan like Bill Gates
like Bono who then you know can talk to
the heads of state who finally meet at
the g8 summits and then make the
decisions we have for this year as it is
a very important year for the globe fund
as we have our replenishment currently
going on with the pledging conference in
october we've produced a little video
where we collected the voices of these
people and i wanted to show you a very
short kind of video clip with these key
advocates of the Global Fund to give you
an example of how they are working with
us because advocacy works in many
different ways through NGOs through
through media through others but if you
really want to get to President Obama or
present Sarkozy or Chancellor Merkel
none of us will be able to pick up the
phone and talk to them or if we write a
letter to them that might be very kind
of us but but they would never read it
but if they get the message from the
right kind of people then that is much
much more influential and that's what
we've been trying over the years to kind
of mobilize these kinds of people
sometimes celebrities who really have
that kind of access and help us in this
effort do you think we get a bit of
running
yeah of a global fund felt I called it a
war chest quite a lot of people laughed
it off say there he goes again dreaming
you know and I love dreams it always
starts with a dream ask yourself what do
you need to leave food a home a job
your family love and health
without health the others are not enough
it's one thing we all have in common if
we are in the same board then a whole at
one end of the boat force all of us at
risk around the world aids tuberculosis
and malaria kill millions of people each
year and handicapped the development of
entire nations these diseases are not
invincible far from it but to fight them
it takes commitment the right strategies
money and leadership the creation of the
Global Fund was one of the kindest most
important things that happened to help
improve people's lives the treatment
whether it's for tuberculosis or AIDS
and malaria is saving lives and that has
a catalytic effect on allowing the
community to take care of itself in 2002
the Global Fund to fight AIDS
tuberculosis and malaria was founded to
bring massive amounts of new funding to
the fight against these three diseases
there's truly an era prior to the Global
Fund and an era after the global
functions when it comes to AIDS in 2001
2002 there was barely anyone on
treatment in the developing world today
it is over four million people who
access antiretroviral treatment the
life-saving therapy for AIDS two thirds
of all international funding to fight TB
and malaria and nearly a quarter of the
money used to fight AIDS is now being
channeled through the Global Fund I
think it's fantastic to see how money
provided by donors turns into real help
real medicine and save the life of real
people through the Global Fund to fight
AIDS tuberculosis and malaria over three
and a half thousand
lives are saved every day that's 1.3
million people every year we can win the
fight against these diseases it's just a
matter of galvanizing the funding and
getting the political will to achieve
this today hundreds of thousands of
health workers around the world are
dedicating their work to saving lives
with resources channeled through the
Global Fund it's the countries that are
in the driving seat the country's decide
on their programs they decide on their
budgets they decide on how the money
will be channeled what we ask in return
are the results a global fund is a
flexible it doesn't make a
one-size-fits-all recommendations the
funds for Cassandra zulte has really
helped drive progress towards the
millennium development goals while
making sure that donor resources are
being put to good use the Global Fund is
also strengthening ways in which
partners can work together to fight
diseases no one can fight an epidemic
alone or the ministry of health or the
public sector or the private sector or
the civil society or the international
organizations when it comes to fighting
an epidemic everyone has to come
together look Global Fund is run very
professionally it sets big goals it
measures itself that's constantly
improving in the injection of resources
expertise from businesses could help the
Global Fund be even more ambitious all
of us can be proud of what we have
established what we have done
but more importantly be conscious of
what still needs to be done there can be
no later in the fight against aids
tuberculosis and malaria if we ease up
these disease very much we either win
this fight what we lose him the success
of the Global Fund is a test of global
solidarity if we are to achieve the goal
of eliminating transmission of the virus
from mothers to children by 2015 there
isn't still a lot of work has to be done
but it is within our reach we can turn
the tide on TV and ensuring that we've
halted and becomes a reverse the
incidence of TB by providing access to
treatment to those who need it we also
have the opportunity to end malaria
deaths just like hiv/aids and TB we have
the tools needed to prevent and treat
malaria death by a mosquito bite no not
in the 21st century when allowing that
these are very big and very bold and
ambitious goals but they're absolutely
achievable
you know what I mean I can talk forever
but you know these people that makes the
difference and I mean obviously we are
grateful that they agreed to be filmed
for what they said but that is a very
powerful message that that helps us
obviously then then to convince
politicians and that is is a key element
of this advocacy when I designed our
strategy for advocacy a couple of years
ago together with my team its summarized
in this slide if you like because in the
end what we need to do is we need to
reach a very small group of people the
leaders of the g8 the leaders of the
richest nations those who meet at the g8
summits and at other meetings you know
and are not many who can reach them
directly that's why you know what I call
celebrity a that's what you've just seen
in the video those those are all kind of
a celebrities there is the united
nations represented by the
secretary-general very influential there
are very often heads of states and
ministers from from implementing
countries and we are increasingly you
know working with them and many have
helped us this year in the lead-up to
the replenishment but that is what what
political advocacy is all about let me
then go very quickly through a number of
slides that is therefore what is also
hopefully tomorrow in the final
communique of the g8 summit in in canada
where the g8 leaders are also committing
to continue their support for the Global
Fund so you will not be surprised if I'm
quite pleased that this is in the in the
final statement if it remains there and
and that will help us to run our
replenishment this year as i said on
october five all the donors will come
together in new york and will then make
their financial contributions for the
Global Fund for the next three years the
chair of that conference is
secretary-general ban ki-moon mr. Kofi
Annan was the chair of the first two
rounds and
mr. ban ki-moon is the current chair and
we have been working for more than a
year preparing all the donors so that
they come prepared for that conference
and and pledged the resources that we
need a few words also to two other kind
of complementary efforts we also need to
increase contributions from what is
called innovative finance and what is
coming from the private sector and I
won't go into a lot of details so that
we have a bit more time for for
discussion must say we we had designed a
scheme that converts debt into resources
for health and we have now just launched
a new initiative together with Dow Jones
that will mobilize resources from the
investment sector there there will be an
index the Dow Jones global fund index
where then you know private and
corporate investors can invest and both
Dow Jones and the number of leading
investment banks have agreed to share
their fees then with the Global Fund so
that we can turn that into resources
that will be available in the fight
against the diseases similarly also we
are working very intensively with the
private sector our flagship program is
product red where a number of well-known
companies are producing certain products
and be part of the proceeds then also go
to the Global Fund you see the names
here the most prominent at the moment
because we currently have the football
world cup going on in South Africa and
our most prominent partner there is Nike
and they are producing special laces and
other products where part of the
proceeds go to Africa and help us
support our programs so these are some
of the innovative ideas that you need as
well because the public donors are
always telling us that resources are
limited and we have to see that we
diversify the income and involve as many
partners as possible but also again for
that it applies what I mentioned before
you need a very good reputation you need
the confidence unit the results
otherwise you will not get those
partners let me now save few words to
conclude about the future directions in
Global Health there has been much
complained that the global health
architecture over the last year's has
become too complex and while we I think
all you know appreciate the increase in
the resources it normally and naturally
goes hand in hand with also an increase
in the number of organizations and
initiatives and partnerships and I know
that this is very confusing also for
many who then have to implement all
these resources I do believe that now is
the time to simplify the structure to
consolidate the efforts and to think
about viable effective and appropriate
structure for the future and I think
this global health architecture for the
future will have a number of important
elements first let me talk a little bit
about wh 0 which obviously is the
leading normative and technical agency
it has the constitute constitutional
mandate to be the directing and
coordinating Authority with respect to
international health and this includes
establishing and maintaining effective
relationships for us also with the
United Nations with specialist agencies
professional organizations NGOs and
others so the wh 0 obviously will play a
critical role in the global health
architecture and needs to be equipped to
do so but every show is not a funding
institution and has never been so so I
think that there should be very clear
division of labor what is the role of wh
0 and what is the role of funding
organizations like the Global Fund then
also we have to you know improve the
relationship between bilateral
initiatives and multilateral initiatives
so there are obviously many bilateral
partners here in the u.s. u.s. id and
PEPFAR but but you know many others as
well and diffident GT zet and CIDA and
and all these agencies jaiku and so on
that are present in your countries I
believe that in the future it doesn't
make much sense that every donor country
will send its own missions and have its
own little projects and so on and
therefore we need a consolidation here
and we need also to think what is the
comparative advantage of bilateral
institutions and of multilateral
tutions the Global Fund like Garvey has
no country presence so we don't provide
any technical support we can't support
countries in developing proposals nor
help you with the implementation we are
simply financing institutions I believe
that the best role for the bilateral
partners is in the future to help
particularly with the technical support
as they have the capacity on the ground
that we don't have but that we find a
better division of labor between those
two channels and finally also probably a
consolidation of multilateral funding
channels in health so how will this you
know future structure look like there is
now an increasing discussion about
consolidating different funding sources
and creating what some have called the
Global Fund for health-related MDGs and
gorg you have also sent a commentary
together with others you know to the
land said that has been published asking
for exactly that but you have been in
good company that in many others like
Jeffrey Sachs and Mary Robinson and and
others who have been calling for this
Global Fund for health-related MDGs and
also the chair of the Global Fund Board
dr. tedros who will be with you tomorrow
morning you know has been an advocate
for that and and has been portrayed in
The Lancet where he has been arguing for
such a consolidated blower fan so I do
believe that this is a move for the
future that we will see over the next
few years a very intensive discussion
about this consolidation how that should
look like and how we can concentrate
these efforts but also then broaden the
mandate of such a fan so that we really
can address all the important you know
aspects of health and finally what is
the effect of the current global
economic and financial crisis that might
be also on many of your minds you know
what will happen in the future we all
know you know we have an unprecedented
crisis in many countries around the
world and the big question is will we
see a continuation of this what happened
over the last kind of 20 years and
increase in the resources for health let
me give you a cup
of answers to that I don't think we will
see an increase of the resources like
this that would be unrealistic and I can
tell you that because I'm visiting many
ministries around the world who would
tell me about their budgetary situation
nevertheless first if you look at the g8
deliberations in Canada and I gave you a
few examples of that you can see that
health is still very high on the agenda
and that is a very positive sign
secondly you can see that politicians
are now more interested in broader
health perspective this year the theme
is maternal and child health but it also
extends to health systems to neglected
tropical diseases and in the near future
we will also have to think about and
address the non-communicable diseases
because that is the growing problem in
many countries around the world and we
will have to think how we can address
that and how we mobilize resources for
that so it will not remain limited to
communicable diseases thirdly the Global
Fund is now firmly established we are
only eight years old but I do think that
we have a significant level of
confidence you know by many partners
around the world so the Global Fund will
not diminish in spite of the economic
crisis it is there to stay and it is
increasingly being discussed as a
potential model for the broader approach
for the future fourth we have to do the
groundwork and develop the right
strategies so that resources will
increase further as the global economy
recovers so some of what I've
demonstrated to you what we've kind of
established as an advocacy model which I
believe has been fairly successful over
the next few years we need them to apply
to the broader health perspective also
as the global economy will pick up again
that we can then also see a continuation
of the increase in resources and fifth
we need very strong joint advocacy to
keep the momentum going so in summary I
think this is a very very critical year
for global health we have the millennium
summit in September that will take very
important decisions about the future of
globe
health we have them the replenishment
meeting and we have only five years left
to achieve the health-related Millennium
Development Goal so I think now is the
time to redouble our efforts and to make
sure that we improve the health of
people that we achieve the results and
that we provide the feedback also the
political leaders that they continue
their support so in difficult economic
times with many of the poor countries
hit the hardest and that is what I often
also say in the capitals of the rich
countries when they tell me that the
budgets are in the constraints I say yes
you are affected by the economic crisis
but many poor countries are even more
affected and they often do take that
into account so in this situation it is
particularly important to ensure that
the health inequities between the rich
and the poor countries do not widen
further in 2010 and the years to come we
need to continue to scale up AIDS TB and
malaria programs at least at the same
pace at the recent years but also
address increasingly the other major
health problems in international
development particularly in health the
first decade of this century was
dominated by hope and optimism we must
ensure that the second decade is not
infused with cynicism from broken
promises that builds the foundations for
a bright future I thank you very much
thank you Chris offer their presentation
maybe we can take a few questions from
the from the group doctors work
for a presentation which is again has
been very good and very educated and we
are happy that the fun is no more as
vertical as it used to be when it first
started and they were appreciative of
that the problem we still have is one
does not know how much of that can
really go into health systems
strengthening I know you've said is
flexible but the focus is still on those
three diseases and enlighten our
proposal sometimes you are really
constrained if I add so much of other
area that are equally important that
will make sure that we are dealing with
the country's health nice you don't know
how far you will go and I don't know how
you will defund the board is going to to
address this yeah I know that is a key
question you know the health system
support but i think it's has already
happened in many countries that a lot of
the resources have gone into what you
would call Health System strengthening
not just into buying drugs or bed nets
and so on we estimate that about thirty
five percent of the total resources went
into you know the health workforce as
you discussed earlier today the training
salaries and so on but also health
infrastructure management systems Emma d
systems and so on and I think that that
is the kind of trend also for the future
but basically my message is the Global
Fund is yours in a sense you might not
always feel like that you think the glow
fund is this organization that is
sitting in Geneva and you don't know
what can we do how can we apply what can
we put in there but also you're sitting
on our board the board is constantly
trying to kind of you know respond to
those questions obviously there is no
better person to address exactly that
question then minister Tedros who will
be with you tomorrow because this chair
of the board of the globe
minister Tedros what he would probably
tell you what he has told you know us
and others many times is he used a lot
of flexibility of the glow found in
Ethiopia and didn't feel kind of limited
by you know yes he's addressing the
three diseases but you know at the same
time used a lot of the resources to
train community health workers always
telling us yes these health workers they
you know provide treatment they also
help to distribute mosquito nets but
they do many other things as well and
the Global Fund is very happy with that
I think they're quite a few of you from
Ethiopia here who know that very well
better than I do but I mean he always
says you know and I helped to build a
lot of health centers you know in the
rural areas and guess what they are not
just addressing the three diseases they
are you know strengthen the health
system overall if the chair of our board
could do that many others can do that as
well so my message is absolutely i think
the direction the future is you know
more investment in the health systems
more broadly we use AIDS tuberculosis
and malaria as the entry point for now
we might discussing you know moving more
and mature maternal and child health in
the future and you will have a fund that
should be there to address your
priorities you know as you define them
so that's how I see the direction of the
fund and and I think you will find a lot
of sympathy for that in the board of and
like your you got k I i will ask a
couple of questions the first question
is where the mdg target here is a left
with only five years to go would you
give us a glimpse of the scenario beyond
2015 yeah the other gays the Global Fund
functions programs and strategies will
there be any changes now with with the
Global Health Initiative coming into the
picture yeah so first what will happen
after 2015 it's a little bit early to
say of course
and and that there is a slight danger in
that you know we'll have a lot of
discussion on that at the upcoming mdg
summit what we don't want to allow is
that you know the donor countries
already say are you know we can't reach
the MDGs so it's coming close now but as
we can't achieve them let's redefine the
targets and so on that's not what we
would like to see we want to say no you
know keep up the momentum we want to
achieve the MDGs and then we can think
what the next targets are because you
know there are many other important
issues that are not addressed in the
MDGs and obviously we will have to look
beyond the MDGs I mentioned for example
the non-communicable diseases they are
not mentioned in the MDGs at all right
so we will have to start to think okay
what's the next phase but what are the
next targets that we have to address but
we have to be careful not to let anybody
off the hook right to prematurely sour
you know we can't reach it and you know
let's achieve those and then set new
targets that that you should define in
your countries you know what are the
next targets that won't do in health
obviously also an education and other
very important issues but but you know
in health we need then to think what do
we do beyond and the second question
excuse me was yeah with the Global
Health Initiative yes um I don't think
it will change the Global Health
Initiative has been launched you know
the over the last year let's say and
just last week that the priority
countries were announced so it's kind of
early stage and and also if you look at
the budgetary allocation it's not that
much money yet that is available for the
Global Health Initiative what we are
saying from the glow of fund is let's
work together let's partner with a
global health initiative and look at the
glow of fund also as a key partner for
the u.s. to achieve the targets that you
will have seen in the Global Health
Initiative and it's so that it's not
just a u.s. initiative the whole world
has to work together to achieve that it
cannot be achieved by the US alone and
definitely not with the
kind of budget that has been allocated
so far so the glow fund is a possibility
also to expand the Global Health
Initiative to get the support of many
other countries of the private sector
and so on and we would be most happy to
work with the Global Health Initiative
to reach those targets as they've been
defined so I think you know it's still
early days but but certainly we've had
quite a few contacts already with our us
colleagues so we want to see a very
close partnership between the Global
Health Initiative and the Global Fund
thank you for your great talk my
question is not Global Fund related it's
more for a process issue I want to learn
from your experience about this process
during our stay here we've been talking
about leadership and accommodating
dissent and one of the issues we
discussed was the fact that sometimes
conclusions of meetings are written
before the meeting begins oh you mean
what I said about the Canadians are
about that yeah I just wanted you to
share your experience on that front yeah
about drafting statements before or hand
hand and I mean do you get people
dissenting and and how do you manage
that process it's very it's a very good
question I think for the g8 there's no
other way but to prepare those
statements long before happen because
you know these leaders come together for
24 hours you know and then they move on
so they have no time to negotiate that
so there are teams you know have been
working for a year to draft those
statements and that's the only way how
you get an agreement at that level but
that shouldn't be a model for for every
important decision right and actually
the Global Fund Board is a very good
example for that because yes we in the
Secretariat you know we be draft
decision points and prepare decisions as
well I mean we can't just you know
come to the board and then think what
are we doing today and you know what
what kind of language will be put in
there but we very rarely come out with
exactly the same language as the
language was when we went in so there
are real serious discussions in the
Global Fund Board some of you might be
familiar with that actually every year
when we launch a new round there are
intensive you know discussions about
shall we launched are we not under what
conditions how will we prioritize so
that would be an example where you go
into such a meeting you have an idea you
have a kind of draft but there's a real
negotiation sometimes until the last
hour and then you come out with a
compromise and I actually like that
because you know you need this spirit
also of of compromise that that people
who are coming from very different
perspectives in the end come together
and can find a consensus and and that is
the way what you can achieve whether the
board as I described it where people
have the equitable you know right not
just to speak everybody can speak but to
make decisions because in the end the
chair knows you know I need a two-third
majority in both groups so that forces
them to work together and they do work
on these decisions and don't come in
with you know precooked conclusions if
you like normally I would be the one
asking you about mental health but i
like most welcome to do that no but i
like your your answer about using the
three diseases as an entry point i
really like that and appreciate that
very much but question is is this I'm
over the years we see a different
emphasis in fighting illness take
malaria it used to be that we looked at
the environment and sprayed the
environment and all of that and then we
put some emphasis on on the drugs and
now we put emphasis on the bed nets and
I just wonder what you think about the
shifting emphasis
and if at some point who determines this
shift and where is the balance in if you
know in the effectiveness because
something is lost always when you you
move like that and I mean so if we take
the example of malaria but we could take
you know other diseases as well the
decision on on what to support what is
the kind of strategy in a sense to
combat disease is not made by the Global
Fund right that's not our expertise and
we don't want to assume that role that
is exactly what I see as the primary
role of the World Health Organization
first of all to kind of develop some of
those policy strategies but then it has
to be adapted to the country level
because in the end it's you who know
what is working best in your country and
whether you want to focus on bed nets or
whether you want to focus on indoor is
it you're spraying you want to focus on
on treatment or on other you know vector
control policies and so on so you know
wh 0 provides the framework the
country's decide and put that into their
proposal and the Global Fund and our
technical review panel is only there to
say are those proposals according to the
internationally established guidelines
or not and then you know is the is the
capacity there to implement that is it
the sound proposal then it will be
approved so so we don't get you know
engaged in that so that's that's the
answer to the malaria equation but I'm
sorry you didn't ask me about mental
health if you wanted to because it's
it's part of what I meant you know we
have to think beyond now right I mean I
just mentioned that the non-communicable
diseases in in general but but I think
we all are aware you know what the what
the current burden of disease is you
will know what the burden of disease is
in your countries we know about the
projections for the future mental health
is very prominent you know among the
burden of diseases for many countries
depression for example we could talk
about accidents and injuries as a major
cause for mobility
mortality other diseases are increasing
and important so I think we need to take
the broader view and and you need to
define in a sense you know what are the
major health problems that you are
struggling with and where you would say
this is what we can do and Finance
domestically and that's always the kind
of foundation that's the basis but then
what are the elements that that we
cannot were the best of our efforts in
the sense you know address but we
believe coming back to the notion of
health as human right that that we
should provide those services and that
that should you know determine the
services of the future thank you so much
this was quite revealing very
interesting I wondered about the
compliance and accountability side which
has been in the news of late and whether
or not the trend and the satisfaction of
the fund itself with the performance
taken as a whole over over the years has
been high or low or medium um I
personally also because you know I've
been on the on the implementing side
have been honestly impressed by the
performance of the programs that we
support you know globally if you take
all the 600 programs and you know we
calculate the average of the targets
they achieve the number is on average
all the programs achieve ninety-four
percent of their targets I think this is
absolutely exceptional and this has
nothing to do with a global fund this is
you who are achieving those results
right we are just providing the money
but that is quite exceptional in terms
of development finance we know from many
institutions if you achieve some would
say fifty percent if you achieve sixty
percent you would say fantastic but but
more than ninety percent of the targets
really achieved and and verified that is
quite
sectional which obviously means that you
know some targets are overachieved you
know it can be bed net distribution it
can be TV in case detection they might
achieve under 20 hundred thirty percent
of the target big they go beyond and
others leg a little bit behind but but
overall the performance is really very
very good and and we measure that very
carefully and and we report regularly on
that so I think that is quite
encouraging actually maybe one or two
more questions if our comments yes I
just had a thanks for a great
presentation I just had a quick question
around complexity which you mentioned I
watched a program recently as aired here
in the US there was an interview of Bill
and Melinda Gates and then Soros they're
doing some really good work trying to
engage other ultra wealthy individuals
to to basically use their wealth for
human welfare globally but at the same
time as you've described me more as good
but with this complexity also has those
challenges kind of beyond governance
which we see you do well within the
Global Fund that's that's within your
control with these external players that
have their own boards and agendas how
how can that be managed yeah excellent
fish and thank you yes I read that
obviously with great interest that you
know the lamina Gates and Warren Buffett
encourage other billionaires to kind of
be more generous and join them in their
effort and I think we all applaud that
but you're quite right I mean you know
what would happen if they do so i think
in not negative but but a less positive
outcome would be that every rich
billionaire wants to start their own
little program right and that can easily
happen because they want the name
attached to a program here and there and
i think that would lead to even more
kind of complexity and more you know
different programs and reporting lines
and all that and i don't think that
would be a very good outcome we have a
very good and constructive relations
with the bill and melinda gates
foundation so there's no overlap
basically whatsoever right they they
partly supported loaf and directly they
give us a hundred million dollars a year
and then they concentrate on areas that
the glow fun does not cover I mean in
particular they invest in research for
example you know malaria vaccine AIDS
vaccine and all that and that's great
because that's not what we do that's
what you know they're much better suited
to do so I believe if you know they
succeed and persuade more of these
billionaires to give I think they would
be well advised to join these other
initiatives not to create new ones right
but either if they want to support
programs on AIDS TB and malaria give the
money to the glow fund if they want to
support vaccines give it to gobby if you
want to support research give it to the
Gates Foundation that's what Warren
Buffett has done you know which is quite
amazing I mean he gave away a lot of his
wealth and said I give it to Bill and
Melinda because they know what they're
doing another example is carlos slim the
at the moment i understand the richest
man in the world is overtaking Bill
Gates that the Mexican businessmen he
joined with Bill Gates in you know
creating some programs in in Central
America I think also that was good that
he didn't try to do something on his own
but say okay I joined forces with those
who exist that's what I meant when I
talked a little bit about consolidation
not you know everybody creating another
you know little program but but let's
bring it together that's also what we
are trying with these companies like
product red I mean you saw nike
starbucks tell Microsoft Apple they
could all do their own kind of programs
here there would that help probably not
it's much better to kind of channel that
through the existing channels and that's
part of the simplification we will
Christoph I want to make sure that you
and will make your flight today
appreciate that so thank you so much for
your time with us today